with january coming to an end it's time
for another tea time x little yellow
book top 10 watch list it's our must
watch list that we create with the
incredible dakota johnson this is an
ongoing thing the lists are fantastic
how many of you like are going what
should i watch sometimes well
come to the little yellow book xt time
and we have got your back our list for
january's theme is new year's
resolutions just kidding because
we have enough of that so instead we're
highlighting rule breaking films and tv
shows
i know
here is dakota sharing a few of our
picks
hi everybody hi drew
um
this
month
on the little yellow book tea time
mashup list of things to watch
our theme is
new year's resolutions just kidding
because
who really can do
them
you know and also
what if you don't you didn't come up
with any or what if you um
haven't started them yet or what if you
simply can't
like me
or what if you just can't get over the
complete dumpster fire that was
last year so we have
boogie nights
and
city of god
and
girl interrupted which is a great film
because
it makes you think wow it's nice that
i'm not an insane asylum or it makes me
think maybe i should be in one
um
and the other one is
itu mama tambien
which is just an awesome film
so that's that okay bye
thank you dakota love you and you can go
to our website for the full list
[Music]